ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى هذه التغطيه
المستمره من العربيه للتطورات في السودان
اذا ساعه على بدء الهدنه المعلن عنها في
السودان ساعه على هدوء من المفترض ان
يشهده السودان بعد اربعه ايام من الاقتتال
والاشتباكات بين الجيش بقياده البرهان
والدعم السريع بقياده حميدتي الهدنه وبحسب
الاتفاق ستكون لمده 24 ساعه فقط بحيث يتم
تامين احتياجات المدنيين وفتح الطرق
امامهم وامام الفرق الطبيه وسط ظروف صعبه
يعيشها السودانيون حاليا
[موسيقى]
الحدث الاهم حاليا في السودان الهدنه
القادمه بعد ساعه من الان عضو مجلس
السياده الانتقاليه السوداني شمس الدين
كباشي اكد في تصريحات للعربيه ان المجلس
وافق على هدنه مقترحه من الامم المتحده
لمده 24 ساعه بشرط ضمان ضبط قوات الدعم
السريع كما قال مضيفا انه سيتم الالتزام
بهذه الهدنه ومراقبه مدى التزام الدعم
السريع بها وعبر الكباش عن اسف مجلس
السياده من التصعيد الحاصل وفشل تهدئه في
البلاد مشيرا الى ان القوات المسلحه كانت
مضطره لدخول المعركه وكشف المتحدث نفسه ان
الانشقاقات داخل الدعم السريع صحيحه مئه
بالمئه مضيفا ان قوات الدعم السريع تستعد
لاستقبال طائرات مساعدات في مروي
الامور
عليها تماما نحن نقدر الوضع انها ان هذه
حرب حرب حرب مدن وحرب المدن معقده ولذلك
نحن نتعامل مع وفقا لذلك الخرطوم مقتضى
بالسكان وبالعمران ولذلك نحن نتعامل مع
هذه الحرب بحسابات دقيقه جدا حتى القوه
نحن نستخدمها بقدر بقدر ما نحتاجه بقدر
الموقف الذي امامنا
صحيح مستخدم الطيران احيانا لضرب
بعض المقرات الذي لا زالت لديه ايضا لقطع
خطوط
وفي مقابل هذه التصريحات اشارت قوه الدعم
السريع في السودان الى وجود مركزين للقرار
داخل قياده الجيش وهو معتبرته تهديدا
للالتزام بالهدنه التي اعلنها الطرفان
لمده 24 ساعه واضافت في بيان لها ان
التضارب في تصريحات قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح
البرهان والصفحه الرسميه للقوات المسلحه
بشان الهدنه يظهر وجود مركزين للقرار داخل
قياده الجيش
هذا وكان اكد يوسف عزت المستشار السياسي
لنائب رئيس مجلس السياده وقائد قوه الدعم
السريع اكد في مقابله مع العربيه ان قوات
الدعم السريع لا تعترض على الهدنه وستتصرف
بمسؤوليه كامله تجاهها نستمع
ذلك فيما يخص الهدنه من البارحه اتفقنا مع
السيد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي هو الذي
اخترع هذه الهدنه وبعد الدول الصغيره
ووافقنا واعطيناه الموافقه كامله على ان
يستجيب الطرف الاخر وللهدنه واليهود
انسانيه
بالامس تم توجيه كل القوات في المواقع
المختلفه قوات الدعم السريع ان تلتزم
بالهدنه وانت تحافظ على المغارات التي
تسيطر عليها ولا تتحرك اي تحرك هجومي او
ان تسهل عبور المدنيين عبر الكبائر التي
نسيطر عليها هذا هذا كان توجيه واضح من
قياده الدعم السريع بالامس واعلن ذلك
اليوم في تغريده قبل خروج الكباشي او
كلامي في نفس الوقت
الساعه الثالثه صباحا نتعرض لهجوم في
القياده العامه
نستطلع الاوضاع من مدينه مروي مع مراسل
العربيه نزار بقداوي نزار اهلا بك معنا
اقل من ساعه تفصلنا عن بدايه هذه الهدنه
المقترحه من الامم المتحده والتي اتفق
عليها الطرفين كيف هي التفاصيل والصوره من
عندك
في مدينه
الملتقى
اكدوا للعربيه بانهم شاهدوا
تحليقا لطائر عسكريه وجهت ضربه جويه
لعشرات السيارات التي خرجت من مطار مروي
هذه المعلومه ايضا كانت قد اكدتها مصادر
عسكريه للعربيه بان
القصف الجوي تعرضت له هذه السيارات بعد ان
اضطرت بفعل المدفعيه الثقيله التي
واجهت بها القوات المسلحه قوات الدعم
السريعه التي كانت تتمركز داخل مطار مروي
الدولي هذه المعلومه اكدتها مصادر وعمليه
القصد بالطيران اكدتها مصادر وشهود عيان
في منطقه الملتقى الجنوبيه مروي على بعد
100 كلم
نعم نزار كانت هناك كذلك معلومات عن وصول
مساعدات الى مروي حدثنا عن التطورات ولكن
هل هناك تفاصيل اضافيه فيما يخص هذه
النقطه
حتى الان الوضع الامني هو الذي يسيطر على
المشهد الجيش السوداني يتمركز داخل
القاعده وداخل المطار وفي محيط هذه
القاعده وامام البوابات الرئيسيه للمطار
بعض الارتكازات شاهدناها في الطرق الرئيسه
امام الجسر الذي يربط بين مدينتي مروي
وكريمه اما فيما يلي مساله الدعم الجيش
السوداني كان قد اكد قبلا في تصريحات ايضا
للعربيه بانه يوافي في معركه ممتده بدات
قبل اربعه ايام هو الان يتحسن ويضع كل
السيناريوهات المتعلقه بالاستمرار في هذه
العمليه وبقوه هذا يفسر حسب ايضا مصادر
العربيه بان الجيش يضع من الامكانيات ما
يمكنه من ان يخطو خطوات اضافيه وخطوات
متقدمه ويمدد من حدود السيطره هنا في مروي
وفي بقيه المناطق في السودان
ما هي انتظارات
الانتظارت الشعبيه لهذه الهدنه نزار بمعنى
ان منذ بدء الاشتباكات كانت هناك حاله من
الارتباك داخل صفوف الشعب السوداني فما
يتعلق بتوفير الاحتياجات الاساسيه كيف
ينتظرون او ما الذي ينتظرونه من هذه
الهدنه بالتحديد
مدينه المروي هنا
او في مباشره على مسار الهدنه الذي ستدخل
حيز التنفيذ بعد اقل من ساعتين من الان او
اقل من ساعه
لان مروي المنطقه التي
حدثت فيها الاشتباكات والعمليه العسكريه
هي فقط في حدود المطار
والقاعده لم يتاثر المدنيون كثيرا
لم يحتاجوا الى ان يقطعوا مسافات طويله من
اجل الايفاء بمتطلباتهم وبمستلزماتهم ليس
من ضروره للبحث عن مصابين وجرحى في
الطرقات كما هو يحدث في مدينه الخرطوم وام
درمان والخرطوم بحري لكنهم
يستشعرون من هذه الخطوه خطوه الهدنه انها
يمكن ان تكون ارضيه لوقف لاطلاق النار
هكذا يقولون وهكذا يصرحون بامكان هذه
الهدنه التي تم للتوافق عليها من قبل
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع بعد الطلب الذي
الولايات المتحده يوم امس يتمنون ويرجعون
ان تكون هذه الهدنه ايضا امتداد لاليه
لوقف اطلاق النار واساس لمرحله جديده ربما
نعم صحيح نزار حدثني منذ قليل عن القتلى
والجرحه هل هناك تعداد لحصيله القتلى
والجرحى على مستوى مدينه مروي على الاقل
نحن في انتظار البيان التفصيلي الختامي
هنالك حديث الان ليس بصوره مؤكده بان
الاوضاع الان في مروي يبدو انها تمضي نحو
السيطره الكامله للجيش السوداني في هذه
القاعده اذا ما مضت الامور وفق المعلومات
وفق المصادر بالتاكيد فان الجيش والقوات
المسلحه سيصدر بيان توضيحي وتفصيلي يوضح
كيف بدات هذه المعركه
هنا او هنالك
صحيح وضحت هذه الفكره اسمح لي فقط ان
نشاهد هذا الفيديو
لصوت اطلاق رصاص وكذلك اصوات الشبكات وهي
صور مباشره تاتينا من الخرطوم لكل هذه
التطورات نحن نتحدث على
الساعه على بدء هذه الهدنه التي المفروض
وافق عليك الطرفان ولكن مراقبون في داخل
السودان يتحدثون عن اشتداد الاشتباكات قبل
هذه الهدنه على كل نستمع لصوت الطبيعي
لهذه الصور ثم نعود
سنكتفي بهذا القدر كنا في متابعه لهذا
الفيديو وهي صور مباشره لعمليات اشتباك
متواصله اطلاق نار دخان كثيف وكذلك هناك
اصوات مدفعيه
وهناك كان حديث في الواقع منذ الامس على
استخدام اسلحه ثقيله فيما يخص هذه
الاشتباكات نتحدث عن هدنه ربما ستنطلق بعد
اقل من ساعه من الان ونحن في مواكبه كل
هذه التطورات وكذلك في رصد الاوضاع قبل
بدايه هذه
[موسيقى]
كده المشاهدين هذا وكانت وثقت كاميرا
العربيه لحظه حدوث انفجار في محيط مباني
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه السودانيه
في العاصمه الخرطوم
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر لسه
الليله ان شاء الله ما في اي غائم في
البلد ذي
[موسيقى]
نزل عليهم
ان شاء الله ما في البلد دي
[موسيقى]
يعني
ومشاهدينا نعود من جديد لمتابعه هذه الصور
صور مباشره من العاصمه الخرطوم حيث نتابع
فيها تصاعد لدخان كثيف وكذلك اصوات
اشتباكات نستمع لهذه الاصوات نحن نذكر
باننا على بعد اقل من ساعه من انطلاق هدنه
منذ يومين كان هناك مقترح اول لهدنه لاربع
ساعات ولكن تم خرق هذه الهدنه بالشبكات
استمرت في اليوم الثاني كذلك اي بالامس
كان هناك مقرر هدنه من الساعه الرابعه الى
الساعه السابعه مساء بتوقيت الخرطوم ولكن
كذلك
كانت هنا المتقطعه ولكن اليوم اتفق
الطرفان كما اكدت الجهه الاماميه على
تفاهم اولي بالالتزام بهذه الهدنه هذه
الهدنه ستنطلق بعد 45 دقيقه من الان
الرابعه بتوقيت او السادسه بتوقيت الخرطوم
وهذه الهدنه الاكيد باننا سنبقى في رصد
المشهد فداخل السوداني ثم يتعلق بهذه
الهدنه وكذلك ثم يتعلق بكل التطورات ان
كان التطورات الخاصه بالتصريحات او
التطورات كذلك الخاصه
بالمبادرات هناك مبادرات واماميه افريقيه
وكذلك دوليه خاصه بطرح مساحه لمحاوله
التهدئه ووقف اطلاق النار
نتابعها
للاشتباكات المستمره في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم كانت هناك تصريحات مشاهدينا خاصه
بما يحدث وخاصه بالمجلس كذلك بمجلس
السياده الانتقالي السوداني حيث اكد شمس
الدين كباشي لقناه العربيه اكد في
تصريحاته بان المجلس وافق على هذه الهدنه
الهدنه المقترحه من الامم المتحده
والمفروض بانها ستبدا بعد اقل من ساعه من
الان بعد 45 دقيقه هذه الهدنه اشترطت
الجهه الامميه ان يكون هناك التزام
للطرفين
بخصوصها شمس الدين كباشي كذلك للعربيه اكد
بانه سيتم الالتزام بهذه الهدنه وسيتم
مراقبه مدى التزام الدعم السريع بها وكان
عبر عن اسف مجلس السياده من التصعيد
الحاصل وفشل التهدئه كذلك في البلاد واشار
الى ان القوات المسلحه كانت مضطره لدخول
المعركه على كل هذه هي صورا مباشره تاتينا
من داخل العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم ونتابع
فيها اشتداد المعارك والشداد الاشتباكات
قبل دقائق من انطلاق هذه الهدنه
تبدا بعد اقل من ساعه من الان اتفقت طرفان
عليها ولكن مراقبون يقولون ولكن مراقبين
يقولون بان هذه الهدنه استبقتها الشبكات
عنيفه بين الطرفين حرب شوارع تشهدها
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم وكذلك بعض
المناطق الاخرى حيث تتمركز قوات الدعم
السريع في
مقابل تمركز بعض مجموعات من الجيش
السوداني
وهذه الصور تاتينا بالتحديد من محيط
القياده العامه للجيش مشاهدينا في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم اذا محيط القياده
العامه للجيش ونستمع لاصوات اطلاق نار
وكذلك استخدام للمدفعيه الثقيله هذا ما
اكده بعض المراقبين وكذلك حتى مراسل
العربيه فداخل السوداني وفقا لبعض
المتابعات كان هناك استخدام للاسلحه
الثقيله لم ينفها الطرفان كان هناك حديث
عن استخدام المدفعيه الثقيله ونتابع هناك
دخان من مختلف النقاط في العاصمه
السودانيه وهذه صور خاصه بقناه العربيه من
محيط القياده العامه للجيش الشبكات مستمره
وهناك اطلاق
للرصاص وكذلك استخدام للمدفعيه الثقيله
[موسيقى]
طيب نبقى في متابعه هذه الصور
ونتابع مع زمينا من مدينه مروي مراسل
العربيه نزار بقداوي نزارنا جديد اهلا بك
معنا نحن العين على ما يحدث في الخرطوم
سنعود لك بعد قليل نزار اكيد باننا سنبقى
في المتابعه التفاصيل الخاصه
بالخرطوم وما يحدث خاصه في محيط القياده
العامه
للجيش هناك اصوات الانفجارات عنيفه بمحيط
القياده العامه بالخرطوم قبل اقل من ساعه
على بدء هذه الهدنه المنتظره والتي اكد
الطرفان الالتزام بها وتحدث مجلس السياده
الانتقالي عن متابعته الالتزام الدعم
السريع بهذه المده هذه الهدنه اكدها وكذلك
حتى دفعت بها جهات عده سنستمع على الصوت
الطبيعي ومن ثم نعود لاستكمال هذه
التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
نتابعها من محيط القياده العامه للجيش
السوداني من الخرطوم هي صور خاصه وحصريه
لقناه العربيه نتابع فيها اصوات لاسلحه
ثقيله تسمع في محيط القياده العامه
بالخرطوم ونسمع كذلك هذه الاصوات من نقاط
متفرقه في محيط القياده العامه صوت
المدفعيه صوت اسلحه ثقيله ودخان كثيف
يتصاعد قبل بدء الهدنه قبل دقائق من بدء
الهدنه المقرره بعد اقل من او بعض تقريبا
35 دقيقه من الان
البعض تحدث عن اشتداد المعارك لرفعي سقف
المطالب قبل بدايه هذه الهدنه ونحن نتابع
هذه الاشتباكات ونتابع كذلك حتى
الاصوات يقول
مراقبون لانها اصوات
انظمه دفاعيه مضاده للطائرات
هناك حديث عن مروحيات استطلاعه وكان هناك
كذلك حديث لمراقبين على طائرات كانت تحلق
في سماء الخرطوم الاكيد بان مراقبين اكدوا
ان هناك استخدام للاسلحه الثقيله وهذه
اصوات لاشتباكات عنيفه وانفجارات عنيفه في
محيط القياده العامه بالخرطوم قبل اقل من
ساعه على بدء هذه الهدنه قبل 30 دقيقه
تقريبا من انطلاق هذه الهدنه ان كان ضيفنا
جاهز معنا من القاهره نساله في هذا الخصوص
تبقى معنا الصوره
ان كان الضيف يجهز معنا الدكتور عمر جاد
طيب من القاهره دكتور ايمن جاد عضو لجنه
الشؤون الخارجيه في البرلمان اهلا بك معنا
دكتور دكتور نسالك عن هذا التطور الذي نحن
نتابعه من خلال هذه الصور في الواقع نحن
في انتظار هدان المفروض بانها ستتيح
المجال لكل الاطراف للتهدئه اولا وكذلك
ستتيح المجال المدنيين لمحاوله قضاء
حاجتهم الاساسيه ولكن قبل هذه الهدنه
بدقائق هناك اصوات لاسلحه ثقيله وكذلك
هناك اشتباكات متفرقه في محيط القياده
العامه للجيش بما يفسر ذلك
يفسر باكثر من طريقه الطريقه الاولى انه
عاده من يدرس تاريخ الحروب
عاده عاده سواء كانت حروب اهليه او
انقسامات داخليه او كانت حروب بين دول
عاده حينما يتم تحديد موعد لوقف للسريان
او وقف اطلاق نار الساعات التي تسبق
بدء سريان الهدنه هي الاكثر شراسه والاكثر
عنفا والاكثر دمويه لان كل طرف يريد ان
يحقق اقصى قدر ممكن من التقدم والانجاز من
وجهه نظره حتى يفرض ذلك في الحوارات
النقطه الثانيه
انه حتى الان لا نعلم مدى امكانيه
الالتزام بهذه الهدنه يمكن ان تكون هناك
اتهامات متبادله يعني طرف يواصل القصف
ويتهم الطرف الاخر بانه لم يحترم
وهذا الطرف الذي لديه القدره وهذا وارد
خاصه وان الهدنه الاولى
شهدت الشبكات متفارقه الهدنه الثانيه كذلك
يوم امس فما الذي يمكن ان او ما الذي يجب
ان يتوفر حتى تنجح هذه الهدنه دكتور فقط
اسمح لي بالتفكير باننا نتابع هذه الصور
الخاصه بقناه العربيه هي صور حصريه
لاشبكات عنيفه في محيط القيادات العامه
بالخرطوم وهذه الصور تاتي قبل اقل من نصف
ساعه او قبل نصف ساعه من بدء الهدنه
المرتقبه في السودان اذا نصف ساعه تفصلنا
على دخول الهدنه حيز التنفيذ المفروض بان
هذه الهدنه ستدخل حيث تنفيذ الساعه
السادسه بتوقيت الخرطوم هذه الهدنه اتفق
الطرفان على الالتزام بها الجهه ستتابع
مدى التزام الطرفين بهذه الهدنه
كنا نتحدث على هدنه سابقه دكتور عماد لم
يتم الالتزام بها ما الذي يجب ان يتوفر
الان تقنيا على الاقل حتى يتم الالتزام
بهذه الهدنه بحسب قراءتك
يعني اتصور
على الارض لابد من ادراك كلا الطرفين بانه
في حاجه لهذه الهدنه تمهيدا لوقف دائم
لاطلاق النار
اذا كان هناك طرف يرى ان ان الوقت في
صالحه هو ان الطرف الاخر على وشك الانهيار
سيخرج هذه الهدنه ويتحقق بان الطرف الاخر
هو الذي خلقها نحن حتى الان لم نلاحظ
مراقبه فاعله من قبل الاطراف مستقله دوليه
الامم المتحده او القوه الكبرى كالولايات
المتحده المفترض ان تكون هناك مراقبه
وتقارير حتى يوجه الاتهام الى من يقوم
بخرق الهدنه او عدم احترامها
هذا الامر متروك لطرفي الصراع لم يعني
تضاف ايديها مساله ان الطرف الذي لن يلتزم
ستفرض عليه عقوبات او سيوجه له الاتهام او
الادانه من جانب مجلس الامن الدولي او
الامم المتحده او حتى الولايات المتحده
وبالتالي هي هدنه في العموم فاذا قلنا ان
الساعات التي تسبق سريان الهدنه هي الاكثر
دمويه وعنفا وهو من نشاهده على شاشاتكم
الان وهو امر منطقي وطبيعي في كل الحروف
وهذا ما نتبعه من خلال هذه الصور نؤكد فقد
الدكتور على انها صور خاصه بقناه العربيه
هي صور حصريه ونحن نتابع من خلالها اشتداد
المعارك في محيط القياده العامه للجيش
حضرتك تعتبر بان اشتداد المعارك هو طبيعي
في مثل هكذا ازمات تسبق الهدى عاده
اشتباكات مستمره والشداد لمعارك عنيفه حتى
يثبت كل طرف من الاطراف كما قلت دكتور منذ
قليل يثبت مطال به ويثبت امرا واقعا قبل
الدخول الى هذه الهدنه ان كانت طبعا هذه
الهدنه سيتم فيها طرح بعض الملفات للنقاش
اذن هذه الصور مشاهدينا نذكر من جديد
بانها صور لتجدد للشبكات العنيفه في
الخرطوم قبل نصف ساعه من موعد
[موسيقى]
وهذه مشاهدينا من اتابعه الان هو اصوات
لاستخدام اسلحه ثقيله منذ اول يوم من هذه
الاشتباكات كان هناك حديث عن استخدام
اسلحه ثقيله في داخل الخرطوم بالتحديد
وكذلك حتى في بعض المناطق والمدن
السودانيه الاخرى التي شهدت هذه الشركات
معنا من الخرطوم مطهر الساتريس وتحرير
صحيفه اليوم التالي اهلا بك معنا سيد طاهر
سيد طاهر نحن نتابع سوره في الواقع يعني
ابلغ من كل تعليق او من اي تعليق هذه
الصوره نستمع فيها لاصوات الشبكات عنيفه
نستمع فيها حتى لاصوات يقال بانها
لاستخدام اسلحه ثقيله في محيط القياده
العامه للجيش
ان كانت معك بعض المعلومات الاضافيه لانه
العين الان وصور العربيه الان على محيط
القياده العامه للجيش ولكن حضرتك وبحسب
متابعتك لما يحدث في عموم الخرطوم هل هذه
الصوره صوره
ممكن ان تكون موجوده كذلك في نقاط اخرى ما
الذي بلغك حول هذه التطورات وهذه التفاصيل
قبل بدء الهدنه
نعم
الامس انتهت المرحله
من العمليه وهي الان في المرحله الثانيه
وهي مرحله وصفها بتامين المواطنين وهي على
المسمى بلغه
الجاهز التمشيط شاهد بعد تدمير مواقع هذه
المليشيات وممراتها
وبعد قطعها
تتحدث عن تامين المواطنين وتتحدث عن تمشيط
فقط وددت ان افهم لان الصوره التي نتابعها
الان هي صوره متبادله كيف كيف تمشيط
هذه القوات بعد
قطع الانت
اج عنها اصبحت
متفلته هاي في مناطق الاحياء السكنيه او
في
يعني مناطق في الاسواق تمارس عمليات النقل
وغيرها
الان المرحله الثانيه هي مرحله
يعني
تنظيف الاحياء منها والمناطق منها والان
العمليات
هذه الفكره ولكن السيد طاهر اسمح لي ان
اتوقف معك على تفاصيل الصوره في عموم
الخرطوم حضرتك صحفي رئيس تحرير صحيفه
اليوم التالي والاكيد بانك ترصد كذلك
الصوره في داخل الخرطوم نحن نتابع الصوره
في محيط القياده العامه ولكن هذه الصوره
وهذه الاحداث هل هي موجوده في اكثر من
مكان في داخل الخرطوم
العمليات بانكسار
الان اصبحت العمليات في مناطق
محطم يعني لا تتجاوز اكثر من ثلاثه او
اربعه مناطق في كل القبولات الخرطوم وكذلك
الولايات
كل الاقاليم الان تعيش السلام
حتى في الخرطوم من التباه محافظات ايضا
على المقاطعه سيد طاهر
اعذرني فقط على
على المقاطعه سنذهب للاستماع لصوت الطبيعي
ومن ثم اعود لك هناك اصوات لانفجارات
عنيفه وهناك ذلك اصوات لاستخدام اسلحه
ثقيله نستمع لصوت الطبيعي لهذه الصور
الحصريه لقناه العربيه من محيط القياده
العامه ومن ثم اعود لك استاذ طاهر
[موسيقى]
اصوات انفجارات عنيفه في محيط القياده
العامه بالخرطوم قبل اقل من نصف ساعه
مشاهدينا من انطلاق هذه الهدنه سنبقى
نستمع لهذه الاصوات سنبقى كذلك في متابعه
هذه الصوره للشبكات المتفرقه في العاصمه
الخرطوم ونسال كذلك بخصوص هذه التطورات
زميله مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي من
الخرطوم سالم اهلا بك معنا في الواقع هناك
اشتباكات عنيفه وهناك كذلك الاصوات لاطلاق
رصاص هناك مدفعيه ثقيله وهناك اسلحه ثقيله
تستخدم في هذه الاثناء قبل دقائق من
انطلاق الهضبه هل يمكن ان تحدثنا سالم على
تطورات في باقي المناطق في الخرطوم كيف
تبدو
الان بدات هذه الاشتباكات مره اخرى على
مشارك بدايه الهدنه الهدنه لم يتبقى لها
سوى اقل من نصف ساعه لتبدا 24 ساعه
انطلقت هذه الاشتباك الان في مناطق
نحن هنا في منطقه هذه المضادات مضادات
الطائرات في منطقه معسكر الشمب في الجهه
الغربيه من منطقه
تتحدث عن طيران
هذه مضادات للطائرات هذه الاصوات التي
اسمعها لكن لا اسمع صوت الطيارات او
الطائرات التي تستهلك لكن هذه الاصوات
تشبه اصوات مضادات الطائرات التي يستمع
اليها الان
مضادات لطائرات نفهم بانه هناك كذلك اما
مروحيات استطلاع او طائرات
هجوميه في سماء الخرطوم في هذه الاثناء
الى جانب المدفعيه الثقيله على الارض صحيح
سالم
نعم هذه صوت المدافع عن
مختلفه في منطقه بحر الان في غرب بحري
وشرق بحري كذلك في منطقه
مستمع الى هذه ايضا
والمضادات وكذلك اصوات لمدافع ثقيله كذلك
في اتجاه الخرطوم كذلك هنالك اصوات لمدافع
في هذه اللحظات كل هذا ابين الانطلاق هذه
الهدنه التي يفترض ان تنطلق السادس من يوم
وحتى سابق الغد ب 24 ساعه وافق عليها
صحيح ونحن نتابع دائما هذه الصوره اذا
اسمح لي ان اذكر سالم بما اوردته من
معلومات تقول بانه نحن لسنا امام اشتباكات
فقط نحن امام استخدام كذلك للمدافع
الثقيله اسلحه ثقيله في العموم هناك
مضادات للطائرات وهناك تحليق لطائرات في
سماء الخرطوم ومن هنا تاتي كل هذه الاصوات
انفجارات عنيفه نتابعها وكذلك صوره في
الواقع لتصاعد دخان كثيف من مناطق متفارقه
من محيط القياده العامه للجيش في الخرطوم
نذكر مشاهدينا بان هذه الصوره تاتينا قبل
بدايه الهدنه ببعض الدقائق ربما 20 دقيقه
تفصلنا عن بدايه هذه الهدنه التي اكدت
الامم المتحده بانها اقترحتها على الطرفين
وبان الجيش السوداني وكذلك دعم السريع
وافقوا على هذه الهدنه على الالتزام بها
ستكون هدنه لمده 24 ساعه بشرط ضمان ضبط
قوات الدعم السريع كما اكدت الجهه الامميه
شمس الدين كباشي اكد بان مجلس السياده
الانتقالي ملتزم بهذه الهدنه ولكنه سيبقى
في متابعه ومراقبه التزام الدعم السريع في
المقابل بكل هذه التفاصيل 20 دقيقه تفصلنا
على بدايه هذه الهدنه المنتظره والتي اكدت
عليها جهات امميه وكذلك حتى دوليه لتمكين
اولا الاطراف من التهدئه وكذلك حتى لتمكين
المدنيين من محاوله التنفس الخروج قضاء
حاجاتهم في هذه الساعات الحرجه التي
تعيشها السودان وفان منذ قليل مراسل
العربيه ببعض المعلومات نعيد ونذكر بها
كما طردنا اسفل الشاشه اصوات مضادات طيران
تنطلق من محيط القياده الع امه بالخرطوم
انهي معك سالم عن انتظارات السودانيين
عموما
انتظاراتهم من هذه الهدنه
نعم الم السوداني ينتظر هذه الهدنه لتحقيق
الكثير من الاهداف التي كان والتحقيقها في
الايام الماضيه بسبب امور نقصت في هذه
الفتره من بدء هذه الحرب وحتى الان
ايضا مثلا بناء الامور المهمه انه كان
اليوم اجتماع والي الخرطوم لمناقشه امر
الخدمات وهذا بعد عقد والي الخرطوم
اجتماعا لاداره الازمه حول الخدمات
بالولايه وهذا الاجتماع ناقش القضايا التي
ينتظرها المواطن في هذه الهدنه حكومه
ولايه الخرطوم عليها
تحقيق كثير من المطالب ناس في الايام
القليل القادمه
انت تقول بان والي الخرطوم اليوم اجتمع
بمساعده لمحاوله ايجاد حلول فيما يتعلق
بهذه الهدنه اجتمع فقط بمساعديه او ان
هناك اطراف اخرى قد تساعده في ات مام
المهام الخاصه بالمواطنين خلال 24 ساعه من
هذه الهدنه ان التزم بها الطرفين
نعم في اجتماع اليوم معنا ادا
ره المسؤولين عن الخدمات الولايه فقالت
حكومه الولايه في بياننا الاجتماع المحطات
محطات المياه بعد تعرضها للقصف بجانب
توفير قوات بتامين القوه العامله في صيانه
الابطال هذه المحطات تعرض لاعطال بحسب
ولايه الخرطوم وهي تحتاج الى صيانه الان
يحتاجون الى قوه لتؤمن
لتؤمن هذه القوه التي
ستعمل للمياه تناول الاجتماع المجهودات
التي الصحفي تامين العلاج في اقسام
الطوارئ والاصابته والعمل مع الجهات
الامنيه لتوفير الحمايه
ولكن سالم هناك صعوبه كذلك في اصول
الكوادر الطبيه الى مختلف هذه المستشفيات
هل ستؤمن مسارات او ممرات امنه لوصولهم
على الاقل في هذه المرحله
هذا ما قالته فيها هذا البيان كذلك ولايه
الخرطوم انها ستوفر يعني تنسق مع الجهه
الامنيه لتوفير
لتوفير حمايه
اضافه للسماح بتحرك عربات الاسعاف وتامين
وصول الادويه الى المستشفيات اذا الولايات
الخرطوم ينتظرها عمل كبير ببدايه هذه
الهدنه طيب ونحن كذلك سننتظر هذا العمل
سنحاول رصده وكذلك سنت
ابع هذه الهدنه شكرا جزيلا الشكر زميلنا
سلم الهاشمي مراسل العربيه من الخرطوم
شكرا جزيلا لك سالم ونحن نتابع دائما مع
هذه الصور مشاهدينا دقائق تفصل السودان
وتفصل المتابعين عموما على انطلاق هذه
الهدنه المقرره بعد ربع ساعه والتي ستمتد
ان تم الالتزام بها لاربع وعشرين ساعه
نستمع لصوت الطبيعه ومن ثم نعود لاستكمال
بعض التفاصيل الخاصه بهذه التطورات
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا ستبقى العين على هذه الصور
ونستكمل مع بعض المواضيع ذات الصله حيث
قالت قوه الدعم السريع في السودان ان هناك
مركزين للقرار داخل قياده الجيش وهو ما
اعتبرته تهديدا للالتزام بالهدنه التي
اعلنها الطرفان لمده 24 ساعه واضافت في
بيان لها انا تضارب في تصريحات قائد الجيش
عبد الفتاح البرهان والصفحه الرسميه
للقوات المسلحه بشكل الفتنه يظهر وجود
مركزين للقرار داخل قياده الجيش
من جهته رئيس حركه العدل والمساواه جبريل
ابراهيم الذي يشغل منصب وزير الماليه دعا
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
لاحترام مؤقته لمده 24 ساعه حتى يتم دفن
الجثث واخلاء الجرحى وفتح وممرات امنه
لخروج المدنيين المحاصرين في مناطق
الاقتتال بجانبي تمكين السلطات من اعاده
خدمات المياه والكهرباء الى المناطق التي
فقدت هذه الخدمات
متابعه هذا الموضوع ونبقى دائما في متابعه
هذه الصور المباشره التي تاتينا من
الخرطوم مع اشتداد الاشتباكات على بعد
دقائق من بدايه هذه الهدنه والبعض يراهن
على هذه الهدنه وخاصه على محاوله تقديم
حلول فيما يتعلق
بالامور او الاساسيات الحياتيه للمواطنين
السودانيين وفي هذا الخصوص سنسال ضيفنا من
عمان عامر شوكه الباحث الاقتصادي والمتخصص
في شؤون النفط والطاقه سيد عامر اهلا بك
معنا ظروف الاقتصاديه جدا حرجه في داخل
السوداني وقد تزيد هذه الازمه اشتدادا
وكارثيه كما تقول الجهه الاماميه نحن امام
هدنه قد تستمر لاربعه وعشرين ساعه هذه
الهدنه الى اي مدى قادره على الاقل لتحسين
الظروف الاقتصاديه في داخل السوداني
سيد عامر هل تسمعني
طيب الى حين ان يجهز معنا سيد عامر
الشوبكين نعود له بعد قليل ان كان الدكتور
جاد جاهز كذلك نعود له
دكتور جاد لازلت معنا بحضرتك كنت تتابع
معنا كل هذه التفاصيل واكدت منذ قليل بان
هذه الاشتباكات طبيعيه انصحها التعبير كما
وصفتها انت منذ قليل قلت بانه هذه
الاشتباكات عاده تكون موجوده قبل كل هدنه
اما لرفع سقف المطالب او كذلك لتثبيت امر
واقع حتى يبني عليه الطرفان
ربما ما يتقدمون به من مطالب فيما بعد في
مرحله
متقدمه ولكن هذه الهدنه يراهن عليها البعض
كذلك لتحقيق بعض بعض المطالب الاساسيه نحن
نتحدث على انقطاع مياه نتحدث على مستشفيات
معطله على عدم قدره الكوادر الطبيه على
الوصول الى هذه المستشفيات هل تعتقد دكتور
بان 24 ساعه قادره على الاقل ان تحل بعضا
من هذه المشاكل
هي اولا لالتقاط الانفاس وان يستريح الشعب
السوداني من سماع ذوي اطلاق الرصاص
والمدافع وما الى ذلك
ويتوقف نزيف الدماغ على الاقل هذا مكسب
كبير ان تتم هدنه لمده 24 ساعه انا تصوري
الشخصي
او وجهه نظري ان كل ما تفضل به مراسلكم من
الخرطوم مهم للغايه قال لوجستكس والاكل
والشرب والمياه نعم هذا مهم لكن انا اعتقد
ان الاكثر اهميه هو محاوله استغلال ال 24
ساعه الهدنه للقيام بتحرك من اجل تمديد
هذه الهدنه لانه
عاده لما بيكون في هدنه كل طرف بيعيد
التموضع في اماكنو ويعيد الاستقواء
الاماكن الطبيعيه وينقل ذخيره ويستعد
لجوله اخرى الحاسمه من وجهه نظره وبالتالي
اذا قلنا ان الساعات التي تسبق الهدنه هي
ساعات
نزيف دماء اكثر واشتباكات اكثر
وتبادل اطلاق كل انواع المقذوفات فان
الساعات التي تلي انتهاء الهدنه تكون كذلك
وبالتالي ربما اتمنى ان يتحرك وفد عربي
من الدول الرئيسيه الفاعله ربما المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ربما معها مصر ربما معها
الامارات يعني ممثلين على مستوى عالي لكي
يذهبوا صباحا باكر الى الخرطوم وعقد
لقاءات على انفراد مع
قاده الجيش وقاده الدعم السريع لتمديد
الهدنه اولا ثم الجلوس الى مائده
المفاوضات هذا هو الهدف الاكبر من لانه لو
لو انتهت الهدنه واستانف القتال اتصور انه
سيكون ضخما للغايه لا سيما ونحن نستمع الى
بعض المعلومات غير المؤكده عن ان اطراف
اقليميه تقوم بدعم هذا الطرف او ذاك اذا
السلاح يتدفق من اماكن مختلفه من السودان
ايضا هناك اطراف يمكن ان تجد لها مصلحه في
اعلان الانفصال فهذه الامور في منتهى
الخطوره لا اقلل من قيمه اللوجستيك المياه
والاكل والشرب لكن اتمنى انه حينما تدق
الساعه السادسه ان يسود الصمت في الخرطوم
وباقي المدن السودانيه معنى ذلك التزام
بالهدنه ثم بعد ذلك اتمنى تحرك دبلوماسي
عربي سريع لن تتحرك الولايات المتحده ولن
تتحرك الامم المتحده ولا اللجنه الثلاثيه
ولا غيره اتمنى تحرك على اعلى مستوى
بتنسيق وتامين
في اي مطار من المطارات بوصول وفود على
مستوى عالي تقوم طوال اليوم ابتداء من
صباح باكر بلقاءات مكثفه مع الجانبين
لوقف تمديد الهدنه ووقفت اطلاق النار
والتباحث حول صيغه لا كاسب ولا خاسر من
هذه الحرب ويتم يعني
صحيح على كل نحن سنبقى في متابعه
ساكتفي معك بهذا القدر اسمح لي فقط دكتور
لمتابعه الصوره الصوره في الواقع
نتابع فيها تطورات جد مهمه قبل دقائق من
بدايه هذه الهدنه دكتور عماد جاد شكرا
جزيلا لك عضو لجنه شؤون الخارجيه في
البرلمان المصري سابقا شكرا دكتور على
المشاركه في هذه التغطيه وتغطيه العربيه
مستمره مشاهدينا نحن في متابعه هذه الصور
الحصريه لقناه العربيه من محيط العامه
للجيش حيث التصعيد الكبير في الاشتباكات
وكما وفانا كذلك مراسلنا من الخرطوم منذ
قليل هو تحدث عن استخدام مضادات لطائرات
ومدفعيات ثقيله في داخل الخرطوم وفي محيط
القياده العامه للجيش ستبقى العين على هذا
الصوره سنتابعها باكثر تفاصيل ونذكر في
الواقع بان هذه الهدنه كانت منتظره تقدمت
بهذا الاقتراح الجهه الامميه ووافق
الطرفان على الالتزام بهذه الهدنه بطريقه
مبدئيه او مبدئيا كانت هناك موافقه على
هذه الهدنه على ان تستمر 24 ساعه وان تتيح
خاصه
للفرق في الداخل السوداني تمكين المدنيين
اما من قضاء حاجاتهم الاساسيه او كذلك حتى
من من الوصول للمناطق التي تتواجد فيها او
يتواجد فيها جرحى وقتل ويصعب في هذه
الوصول لهم في هذا الاطار كان مدير منظمه
الصحه العالميه تدرس ادهانوم كان دعا طرفي
الصراع كذلك في السودان لاتاحه امكانيه
الوصول الى المرافق الطبيه وقال في هذا
الاطار انه من الواجب على جميع الاطراف
التاكد من اتاحه القدره على الوصول غير
المقيد كما قال والامن الى المنشات الصحيه
لجميع المصابين والذين يحتاجون لرعايه
طبيه وهنا نتحدث عن مستشفيات توقف العمل
بها عن كوادر طبيه كذلك تعطل وصولهم الى
المستشفيات هناك مستشفيات خاصه بغسيل
الكلى منذ اليوم الاول من الاشتباكات
توقفت عن الخدمه الكوادر غير قادره على
الوصول لها هناك انقطاع للمياه وهناك خاصه
شح في المواد الغذائيه وربما هذه الهدنه
ستمكن هذه الفرق لمحاوله الوصول لهذه الم
ناطق وكذلك
لتقديم المساعده للمدنيين نستمع لصوت
الطبيعي لهذه الصور ومن ثم نعود مع اكثر
تفاصيل فيما يخص هذه التطورات نتحدث
مشاهدينا عن دقائق قبل بدء الهدنه
بالتحديد نتحدث عن ست دقائق قبل بدء
الهدنه في السودان نستمر
نتابع هذه الصور ونلاحظ كذلك مشاهدينا
وكان اصوات الاشتباكات واصوات الانفجارات
العنيفه التي كنا نتابعها منذ قليل وكان
هذه الاصوات تراجعت او خفت ربما مع اقتراب
بدء الهدنه ولكنها عادت طيب هذه الاصوات
كنا نتابعها بوتيره شديده قبل ساعه من
الان ونحن رصدنا كل هذه التطورات وكل هذه
التفاصيل سواء في محيط القياده العامه
للجيش او كذلك حتى في مختلف نقاط الاخرى
في الداخل السوداني ولكن هذه الاصوات لا
زالت مستمره نتحدث عن خمس دقائق قبل بدء
هذه الهدنه اصوات لاسلحه ثقيله مراسلنا
كان نتحدث كذلك عن اصوات لمضادات لطائرات
ومدفعيات ثقيله استخدمت في هذه الاشتباكات
مراقبون يقولون بانه بين قوسين من الطبيعي
التصعيد في مثل هكذا
هذا صوت لمدفعيه ثقيله نستمع للصوت
الطبيعي
طيب نعود من جديد نحن نتحدث عن دقائق قبل
بدء هذه الهدنه ونذكر بان هذه الهدنه
ستتيح خاصه
الامكانيه للفرق الانسانيه والاغاثيه
للوصول الى مناطق
حصلت فيها الشبكات ولكن مع احتداد
الاشتباكات تعذرت الفرق للوصول الى هذه
المناطق وهذا ما عطل كذلك حتى تحديد
الاحصائيات او الاعداد النهائيه للجرحى
والقتل من جراء هذه الاشتباكات هذه الهدنه
ستمكن كذلك والي السودان كما وفانا منذ
قليل مراسل العربيه والسودان كان اجتمع
بمساعده اليوم وكان هناك حديث عن توصيل او
ايصال مساعدات غذائيه ومساعدات طبيه
للمحتاجين في المناطق التي تحيط الشبكات
والتي تعذرت فرق الانقاذ لم تتمكن من
الوصول لها على العموم هناك انت عديده
فيما يخص هذه الهدنه انسانيه اغاثيه وكذلك
حتى سياسيه البعض يعول عليها ويقول بانها
قادره ان تمدد اذا ما التزم الطرفان بها
هذه الهدنه ربما ستمدد وربما ستطرح حلول
كذلك لوقف الاقتتال في هذه الاثناء تصعد
كبير في الاشتباكات في محيط القياده
العامه بالخرطوم قبل بدء الهدنه ثلاث
دقائق او اقل دقيقتين قبل بدا هذه الهدنه
ولكن الاشتباكات لا زالت مستمره بوتيره
اخف ربما من وقت سابق ولكن هذه للشبكات
مستمره مشاهدينا من محيط القياده العامه
للجيش في الخرطوم هذه صور للعربيه وكنا
نتابع من خلالها اصوات للشبكات واصوات
كذلك اطلاق القذائف المدفعيه واصوات
مضادات الطائرات نست مع لصوت الطبيعي نعود
فيما بعد
مشاهدينا هذه الساعه اكتملت ولكن تغطيه
العربيه مستمره
للتطورات فداخل السوداني دقيقه تفصلنا عن
بدء هذه الهدنه مع بدايتها ستبدا معكم
الزميله ليال الاختيار في متابعه تفاصيل
اولى الدقائق الخاصه بهذه الهدنه هدنه
امميه اتفق الطرفان على الالتزام بها من
المقرر ان تستمر لاربعه وعشرين ساعه وان
تمكن الاطراف اما من وضعه حظ لهذا تصعيد
العسكري بمحاوله تمديد هذه الهدنه او كذلك
من طرح بعض الطرق لايصال المساعدات
الاغاثيه والانسانيه بعد قليل تتابعون مع
الاختيار استكمال هذه التطورات لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات